there's something out there i'm coming
with you
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
have you ever wanted to be noticed so
badly you didn't even care what it was
for holland danny from work what are you
i'm a writer going to paris for it
hey get picked i'm gonna get lots of
pics
emma i got invited to a writer's retreat
in paris
yes really
we have some breaking news at this hour
a string of terrorist attacks struck
paris this morning
leaving dozens dead and many more
injured
[Music]
[Applause]
creator take pity upon these kids
damn
worlds are always terrible any idea what
we should do with our last day if i had
any ideas i would have asked you to blow
my brains out 35 minutes ago
we're not gonna see tomorrow which means
today we get to do whatever we want with
no consequences so let's use that
opportunity to do some good
are you in
we'll do it right we'll do it together
my cousin spent the last eight years in
prison sorry i'm late i'm just trying to
help it but that fool won't listen to me
why does your body still look 19 but
your face looks 56 food
people love buying cupcakes from ex-gang
members boy oh boy be sure some yummy
cupcakes [ __ ] do you want me to relapse
you buy a cupcake
thank you red velvet is an amazing
choice to look up and see those names i
know i'm in a place of gods it's show
time it was greatness the lakers do have
the personality of los angeles we have a
terrific team this is the lake show
do you hoop
basketball show play
if we're good we can help mom and dad
when one person in the family scores
the whole family scores
jackson police chief is taking questions
now on my watch i will always protect
the city and it's all for you
it's tyrone i think i can
i need that debt you owe me
what did you do to my wife
[Music]
not everyone is meant to make a
difference
peter parker
find spiderman or i'll peel the flesh
off her bones i'm spiderman
no more
today garden heights is reeling after
the shooting of a 17 year old black
teenager by a white police officer
we live in a complicated world it
doesn't seem that complicated to me it's
about black people poor people everybody
at the bottom when you're ready to talk
you talk don't ever let nobody make you
be quiet
the music event of summer is back
cma fest said are we feeling good
tonight or what
33 million viewers have made abbott
elementary a hit and a cultural
phenomenon that is certified fresh on
rotten tomatoes sweet baby jesus and the
grown one too
[Music]
you